en las vi los investigadores tratan de
comprender Los motivos del tiroteo que
dejó a seis personas muertas en una
escuela cristiana este lunes incluidos
tres niños la policía cree que Audrey de
28 años atacó a los estudiantes al azar
pero que sí preparó a conciencia al
ataqué con mapas detallados que fueron
encontrados en su domicilio se
concentran ahora en el perfil
psiquiátrico del atacante
los médicos lo atendían por un trastorno
emocional las fuerzas del orden no
sabían nada del tratamiento que estaba
recibiendo pero sus padres creían que no
debía tener armas tenían la impresión de
que no poseía ninguna después de vender
la única arma en su poder resultó que
había estado escondiendo varias de ellas
en la casa
según la policía el tirador compró
legalmente siete armas de fuego en cinco
armerías locales diferentes y uso tres
de ellas durante el ataque el presidente
Joe quien visitará el lugar de la
tragedia reiteró su llamado a prohibir
la venta de las armas de asalto una
preocupación que rechazó el líder de La
minoría del senado John junie
agradecemos la rápida respuesta de las
fuerzas del orden y creo que cualquier
debate sobre legislación es prematuro
hay una investigación en curso y creo
que tenemos que dejar que los hechos
salgan a la luna
en Estados Unidos circulan unas 400
millones de armas que en 2020 causaron
más de 45.000 muertes por suicidio
accidente u homicidio según los centros
para el control y la prevención de
enfermedades
[Música]